ها نحن في واشنطن العاصمة وسط
خلل آخر، العالم كله
ينظر إلى ما يحدث في المنزل
والإطاحة التاريخية لرئيس البرلمان هي
الديمقراطية الأمريكية في ورطة نعم
بالتأكيد إنها في ورطة لقد كانت في
ورطة قبل هذا الحادث الأخير أه
هذا فقط أه يجعل  من الواضح تمامًا
لأي شخص ينتبه أه أن
لدينا حزبًا سياسيًا واحدًا
للأسف هو في وضع رهينة مطلق
مع أعضائه الأكثر تطرفًا
وأه كيفن مكارثي الذي تعلم أنه
ليس لدي أي علاقة معه من
أي نوع ولكن عندما فعل ذلك بالفعل  الشيء
الصحيح للبلد ومنع
أهنا من الخوض في إغلاق حكومي
تمت معاقبته وعوقب
لأنه عمل مع الديمقراطيين كان
يعمل من أجل خير البلاد
ولم يكن يستمر في كونه أسيرًا لليمين
المتطرف لذلك
لقد أطاحوا به أه كان عددا قليلا جدا
كما تنظر أه التصويت أه لكن
الآن أه نحن تعلمون يحصدون
عواقب سوء سلوكهم فهل كان
ينبغي للديمقراطيين أن ينقذوه إذا جاز
التعبير كان يجب أن يصوتوا
لإبقائه  كما تعلم، كانت هذه
دعوة صعبة جدًا للتجمع الديمقراطي ولكن
المشكلة كانت بالنسبة لهم كما أفهمها، فقد
كان غير جدير بالثقة على الإطلاق بأي
مقياس أه أه مباشرة بعد أن
ساعدوه في إبقاء الحكومة مفتوحة كما
تعلم أه بدأ  إلقاء اللوم عليهم في كل
أنواع الأمور الخارجية التي تعرفها وفي
مرحلة ما زعيم فقد كل
مصداقيته أه في التعامل مع
المعارضة حيث تريد أن يكون لديك
خط اتصال مفتوح تريد أن
تكون قادرًا على الثقة بكلمته أم سوف
اه كما تعلم تطلب مساعدتهم ولا
تحصل عليها يقال أن
المتنافسين الرئيسيين على منصبه هم جيم
جوردان الذي تعرفه جيدًا من
بنغازي ولا أعرفه جيدًا لقد شاهدته
وأه كما تعلم حدقت فيه
لمدة  11 ساعة بينما كان يختلق أشياء
عني، لذلك لا أعرفه ولكنني
رأيته وهو يعمل، فماذا يعني
إذا حصل على المتحدث جيدًا، أعني
أنه أحد
قادة السيرك الرئيسيين  تم
إنشاؤه في الحزب الجمهوري منذ
عدة سنوات أم ليس لدي أي
معرفة داخلية حول ما
سيفعله الجمهوريون لمن سيصوتون له في نهاية المطاف
ولكن متى يضعون البلاد أولاً فهم
لا يمثلون أغلبية حتى
الحزب الجمهوري أه  عندما تنظر إلى
المتطرفين في المنزل فإنهم
بالتأكيد لا يمثلون أغلبية
البلاد وأنت تعلم أن على شخص ما أن
يقف ويقول ما يكفي، كما تعلم أنه من الممكن أن
تكون لدينا خلافات، أنا أؤيد ذلك تمامًا، لقد
كنت في مجلس الشيوخ لمدة ثمانية  سنوات
عملت مع الكثير من الجمهوريين وأنت
تعلم عارضتهم عندما أه لم أوافق
ولكن في مرحلة ما يجب أن يكون هناك
رد فعل عنيف ضد سيطرة هذه
المجموعة الصغيرة من المتطرفين
ولا أعرف أه من سيقود  ذلك ولكن اه دعونا
نأمل أه أيًا كان من يصبح
المتحدث الجديد، فإن العلامات التجارية كما
قلت الثمانية أو مهما كان عددهم هم
الأقلية من الجمهوريين
الذين خرجوا من رئيسهم، فقد فعلوا ذلك
بصوت عالٍ أيضًا وهم يشجبون دعم أمريكا
لأوكرانيا و  قول لا لا لا نحن
نهتم بأمريكا أولاً، ليس
بأوكرانيا، فهذا ليس في
مصلحتنا، هل تعتقد أن هذا
سيستمر؟ الرئيس بايدن يخطط لإلقاء
خطاب رئيسي من أجل دعم
ما تفعله إدارته
للدفاع عن الديمقراطية في  أوكرانيا، ما هو
شعورك حيال هذا ونصيحتك
جيدًا؟ أعتقد أن أغلبية
الكونجرس على جانبي الممر لا تزال
تدعم تقديم المساعدة لأوكرانيا،
ومساعدة أوكرانيا في الدفاع عن نفسها. فهم
أن معركة أوكرانيا هي معركتنا.
افهم أن الديمقراطية تكافح
ضد دولة أخرى.  الاستبداد الذي يمارس
أه همجيًا في الغزو ويرتكب
جرائم ضد الإنسانية والإبادة الجماعية
يجب هزيمته لذلك أعتقد أن أغلبية
الكونجرس تمامًا كما لا تزال
أغلبية الجمهور تؤيد أه
مساعدة
أوكرانيا سيكون التحدي إذا كان من
رئيس مجلس النواب المنتخب يتحكم بطريقة ما في
الكلمة لذا لا يمكنك الحصول على تصويت لذلك لدينا
أغلبية تمامًا مثلما كانت لدينا أغلبية
لإبقاء الحكومة مفتوحة حتى
تعلم أخيرًا سمح مكارثي
بإجراء تصويت مع الديمقراطيين وعدد كبير
من أه  أيها الجمهوريون، لذلك يجب أن
يكون هناك قدر هائل من
الضغط والمناورة للحصول على هذا
التصويت لأن مجلس الشيوخ سيصوت على
الاستمرار في تمويل أوكرانيا،
وسيطلب البنتاغون الاستمرار في تمويل
أوكرانيا، فهم يفهمون المخاطر لذلك كما
تعلمون  سيكون النضال في
مجلس النواب وسيتعين علينا جميعًا بذل
كل ما في وسعنا لفرض التصويت
لأنه إذا حصلنا على تصويت، فستحصل أوكرانيا على
المساعدة التي تحتاجها،
لذلك عندما تنظر إلى كيفية المضي قدمًا
في عملية فرز الأصوات، فإنك تقول  هناك أي
مجال لبناء ائتلاف يمكن أن
يحدث، هناك جمهوريون براغماتيون
كما تقول، هل يمكن أن تكون هناك
طريقة جديدة تمامًا لمحاولة تفعيل
التشريعات
والحكم عبر الأحزاب من قبل الديمقراطيين
وبعض الجمهوريين الذين يشكلون ائتلافًا
جيدًا كما رأيت  أه عدد
الجمهوريين الذين صوتوا مع
الديمقراطيين لإبقاء الحكومة مفتوحة، لذلك من
الواضح أن هناك حسًا سليمًا أه أنت
تعرف أن ساي جزء من التجمع الحزبي الجمهوري
في المنزل ولكني أعتقد أنهم
يتعرضون للترهيب أه في كثير من الأحيان كما تعلم
يقولون ويفعلون  الأشياء التي يعرفونها
أفضل من قولها أو فعلها، وسيتطلب ذلك
منا هزيمة تلك الإجراءات الأكثر تطرفًا
أه والأشخاص الذين يروجون
لها من أجل محاولة الوصول إلى
أرضية مشتركة حيث يمكن للناس
العمل معًا مرة أخرى، هذه هي الطريقة التي
اعتادوا عليها  أقصد أنه كان لدينا أنصار أقوياء جدًا
في كلا الحزبين في الماضي أه
وخاضنا معارك مريرة جدًا حول كل
أنواع الأشياء المتعلقة بالسيطرة على الأسلحة
وتغير المناخ والاقتصاد والضرائب ولكن
لم تكن هناك تلك القصة الصغيرة عن
التطرف الذي يلوح كما تعلم وهو يهز
كلب أه الحزب الجمهوري كما هو الحال
اليوم وللأسف الكثير من هؤلاء
المتطرفين هؤلاء المتطرفين الكبار يأخذون
مسيرتهم ERS من دونالد ترامب الذي
لم يتبق له أي مصداقية بأي مقياس
فهو فيه فقط لنفسه وهو الآن
يدافع عن نفسه في الدعاوى المدنية
والأعمال الإجرامية ومتى ينفصلون
عنه، كما تعلم لأنه في مرحلة ما تعلم أنه
ربما تكون هناك حاجة إلى إلغاء
برمجة رسمية لأعضاء الطائفة
ولكن يجب أن يحدث شيء ما وكيف
تفعل ذلك لأنك قلت إن عليك
هزيمتهم عن طريق  هزيمة زعيمهم زعيمهم
هو دونالد ترامب حتى أنك
قلت أنك تتوقع منه أن يكون
المرشح الجمهوري كيف
يتغير هذا على
الإطلاق في هذه المرحلة أعتقد للأسف أنه سيظل على
الأرجح المرشح وعلينا أن
نهزمه ولدينا  لهزيمة
أولئك الذين ينكرون الانتخابات كما
فعلنا في عامي 2020 و
2022، وعلينا أن نعرف فقط أن نكون
أكثر ذكاءً بشأن الطريقة التي نحاول بها
تمكين الأشخاص المناسبين داخل
الحزب الجمهوري، كما تعلم أن نانسي بيلوسي
حصلت على أغلبية خمسة أصوات.  عندما
كانت رئيسة البرلمان، حصل كيفن مكارثي على
أغلبية خمسة
أصوات، مررت نانسي بيلوسي
التشريعات التبعية وكان من الواضح أنها كان لديها أعضاء
داخل تجمعها الحزبي الذين تعرفهم يتنوعون
عبر مجموعة واسعة من المعتقدات
والأيديولوجيات السياسية، وقد أبقت الجميع
معًا وأبقت الجميع يركزون
على المستقبل.  لم يستطع فعل ذلك ولذلك
دفع الثمن ولكن الأهم من ذلك أن
البلاد دفعت الثمن، ولذا عندما ترى
تنافسًا آخر بين
ترامب والرئيس بايدن،
ما الذي يدور في ذهنك
وخاصة كيف تتعامل مع
هذا الشخص الذي هزم  في عام
2016، ما زلت تفعل ذلك نظرًا لكل ما
قلته، فأنت تعرف التجاوزات الجنسية للاحتيال المدني
وفقًا للمحاكم،
كيف لا يزال هذا يحدث، إنها
الحكاية الكلاسيكية عن أه استبدادي
أه شعبوي أه الذي
يسيطر حقًا على  نفسي عاطفي
أه احتياجات ورغبات
جزء من أه
السكان وقاعدة
الحزب الجمهوري مهما كانت
مجموعة الأسباب وهو
عاطفي
ونفسي أه يرى فيه من
يتحدث باسمهم وهم مصممون على
الاستمرار في التصويت  بالنسبة له
يحضر مسيراته، ارتدي
عينيه التجاريتين لأنه لأي سبب من الأسباب هو ورفاقه كما
تعلمون سلبيون للغاية، شكل سيء
من السياسة يتردد صداهم معهم ربما
لا يحبون المهاجرين، ربما
لا يحبون المثليين أو السود أو
المرأة التي  حصلوا على الترقية في العمل
ولم يحصلوا عليها أيًا كان السبب الذي
يجعل أمريكا عظيمة مرة أخرى، كان محاولة
أه لعودة الحنين إلى مكان
تعرف أن الناس فيه يمكن أن يكونوا مسؤولين
عن حياتهم ويشعرون بالتمكين ويقولون ما
يريدون وإهانة أي شخص يأتي  في
طريقهم وكان ذلك جذابًا حقًا
لجزء كبير من
القاعدة الجمهورية أه لذا فهو مثل عبادة ويجب على
شخص ما أن يكسر أه كما تعلم
كسر هذا الزخم ولهذا السبب
أعتقد أن جو بايدن سيهزمه
وآمل بعد ذلك  ستكون النهاية
وستنقطع الحمى وبعد ذلك أه
يمكن للجمهوريين أن يحاولوا العودة إلى ما تعلمونه وهم
يتشاجرون حول القضايا فيما
بينهم وينتخبون أشخاصًا على
الأقل كما تعلمون مسؤولين وخاضعين
للمحاسبة هل تشعرون بالقلق من أن
مرشح حزب ثالث على الحزب الديمقراطي
يمكن للجانب أن يحبط فرص جو بايدن أنا
دائمًا أشعر بالقلق بشأن وجود طرف ثالث
وهذا ما حدث لي كما أه
يمكننا جميعًا أن نتذكره وأه ساعده الكثير من
القوى الأخرى ويمكن أن يحدث ذلك مرة أخرى
هذه المرة أه لذا بالطبع أنا قلق بشأن أه أي
شخص  من قد يأخذ الأصوات من أه
الرئيس بايدن لأنك تعلم أنني في
المعسكر المسيحي الذي يقول لماذا تقوم
بالفعل بتعيين سياسي، أنت تعرف ما الذي
تريده وما أريده هو
شخص يمكنه إنجاز المهمة
وبايدن لديه  لقد قام بعمل رائع بكل
المقاييس، كما تعلمون، لقد تحدث الناس
عن البنية التحتية إلى الأبد، لقد مرر مشروع
القانون، لقد تحدث الناس عن خسارة
التصنيع المتقدم لصالح الصين، لقد
مرر مشروع القانون، لقد تحدث الناس عن
الحصول على طاقة نظيفة في الواقع لإنتاج
المزيد والمزيد من الوظائف، لقد مرر
مشروع قانون التفاوض على أسعار الأدوية، كل
هذه الأشياء التي حاول الكثير منا
إنجازها، كما تعلمون، لقد أنجز مجلس الشيوخ وما
بعده
وسيغير حياة الأمريكيين إلى الأفضل
وسيعزز وينمو
اقتصادنا وعندما الناس  قل حسنًا، لا أعرف
انتبه، يرجى الانتباه
إلى ما أنجزه ولكن إذا
كنت لا تريد أن تكون معه على
أساس الجدارة مثلما أكون معه لأن
البديل يمكن أن ينهي ديمقراطيتنا
وأنا لا أفعل ذلك.  قل ذلك
باستخفاف